but first up he is the junior senator
from Minnesota who serves on the Senate
Judiciary Committee we love the
Honorable Al Franken over here how I
bail you said it all those years ago but
it's going to turn out to be the Al
Franken decade
it's the Al Franken millennium okay all
right so out you know I've talked to you
personally about how you know yeah I'm a
great admirer because you do things that
the rest of us wouldn't do like have
lunch with Republican senators it's fine
you know what they're saying behind
closed doors there must be they must be
kind of going batshit over this Donald
Trump administration to give us a little
insight into what's happening behind the
scenes well there's a range and what
they'll say and some will say that he's
not right mentally and then some are
harsher
no not there God that was a cheap that
was cheap there are some who I guess
don't talk to me and you know I haven't
heard a lot of good things and I've
heard some great concern about about the
president's temperament okay well that's
very diplomatic of you not very what I
don't think this was diplomatic but okay
I'll take it I'll take her I saw this
today 51% of Trump voters think Trump
should personally be able to overturn
decisions by judges I know you and I are
both people who believe in civics
because we're old enough to remember
when they taught civics in school I
remember when you used to be I've seen
you do this on TV draw a map of the
United States from that's geography
civics no okay we roam I'm with you I'm
with you while you're in the Senate on
my HBO
no well what's interesting about that I
saw that I think it came out last night
or something and and this is a proposed
the decision by the Ninth Circuit that
that didn't surprise me the 52 or 51
percent of Trump voters what was
heartening was that it was only about 25
percent of American so that means that
it was only about 5 or 10 percent of
Americans didn't understand to exert
didn't understand the that a federal the
federal judiciary is independent okay I
mean it was frightening to me that
anybody in America would basically be
saying we should make this man of all
people a dictator because that's what
this is I know but it says that 48 or 49
percent of Trump voters understood
understood this and that's good that's
good I I really you know that's I'm
buoyant why I wasn't has really made you
an optimist Dale and I I appreciate that
it's half full yeah yeah tactile okay so
all right so I don't know what they're
half full of but they're half full
okay you're going to meet with the man
that Donald Trump wants to put on the
Supreme Court right yeah you're on that
committee okay yeah I'm hoping you're
going to say to him your name is not
Merrick garland so I can't vote for you
I was asked by the White House Counsel
who because I'm on the Judiciary
Committee who I would like to see a
point I did say Merrick garland and or
someone like Merrick garland who's a
consensus guy but my feeling is we're
going to have hearings you know I think
this guy I don't want another of five
four conservative activist judiciary
that is a that votes to citizens united
in that and so I guys going to have to
overcome a huge bar for me okay but
isn't it not about the qualifications
but about the fact that that pick was
stolen and what and you know I mean I
really but what if what am I going to do
about it the Democrats cannot let that
stand we cannot have two rules one for
Republicans and one for Democrats and
okay so I hear everybody applauding but
just what just stop employing for a
second say they have the majority and we
can't stop them from having hearings and
so we're going to have hearings now what
I'm saying is is that the Roberts Court
has been a pro activist pro corporate
Pro pollution pro big-money in in in
campaigns and in in elections and I'm
not going to okay a another five for
Roberts Court okay
so a Time magazine came out for
impeaching Donald Trump numbers and the
cover I have no doubt that if Hillary
Clinton was president they would already
have begun impeachment and hearings it
doesn't matter about what they just
would have done it time says the
emoluments clause which is basically and
obviously the Trump family is in
violation of this you cannot take gifts
from foreign countries they're doing it
all the time to say nothing of the
mental problem how when will the
impeachment hearings start let me remind
you again that the Republicans are in
the majority so I think it'll be it's
months and months away
look I know every I know everybody wants
to click thick on this but this is going
to be a bit of a marathon but I'm so
encouraged you're right that what this
week is been incredibly encouraging and
the energy around the country we're
seeing red districts where people are
showing up at the town halls hundreds of
people are showing up at the town hall
there's a tremendous amount of energy
and I want to encourage people to keep
that up right and it really helps them
we got thousands hundreds of thousands
of calls about Betsy DeVos at the Senate
and that makes a difference because she
is unnoticed now and she's not going to
be able to do a lot of the things that I
think she wanted to do because of that
like Walker like when people new makes a
cute
doesn't even do that today it would have
been the first time okay so Donald Trump
first language of public school yes she
could she went protestors wouldn't let
her walk into the school yeah and would
have been the first time I got the joke
back I would be audience with laughing
alright last question now then I'll let
you go I appreciate your time okay
Politico says that there was a meeting
yesterday and Donald Trump with ten
senators six of whom were Democrats and
Donald Trump said to Kelly Ayotte who
was the senator Republican senator from
New Hampshire who lost narrowly as he
did in message hidden in New Hampshire
Donald Trump said in this meeting
thousands of people were brought in on
buses from neighboring Massachusetts to
illegally vote in New Hampshire so once
again the president is seeing multitudes
that no one else sees and it said there
was an awkward silence an awkward
silence
and there were six Democratic senators
in the room I was hoping you if you are
one of those senators you wouldn't have
just been awkwardly silent and you would
have said no excuse me mr. president
that didn't happen I would have said
something like that
you wouldn't I would read oh come on
what is that you got to stop doing this
mr. president right you know just stop
it I mean the three to five million
illegal people didn't show up and and
and vote for him all of them for Hillary
and it didn't happen and just stop doing
that it is it's very disturbing and I
asked Jeff sessions about this in the
judiciary hearings and I said did you
know you the Attorney General is the one
in charge of the laws in this country
including election laws did you kind of
discuss this with him
you know you know our are you concerned
about this and this is very very very
disturbing that the president has a
habit of either imagining things or
making stuff up that's not we it's
really outside the norm not just the
president's but of human being all right
now you were great at the hearings we
love you for it
senator Al Franken everybody